welcome everyone my name is yeti
Komarovsky I'm working on world the
University of Technology in the [ __ ]
of electronics and information
technology and today I will talk about
similarity learning using deep neural
networks so first I will do a kind of an
introduction why we even need the
similarity learning and what can use it
for what kind of problems we can solve
using this similarity learning approach
well to start with let's do a quick
introduction so basically currently in
the recent years the neural networks
made a big progress in terms of the
virus classification approaches like if
you classify images or audio data there
was a huge progress during the last ten
years can be visualized by sorry results
of the large-scale visual challenge when
there is a challenge run every year when
the task is to classify images whoever
they contain a zebra a cat car or a
table and we've got in this challenge
we've got like a thousand categories of
objects and the task is to classify
these images assigned to a correct
category top 5 error rate that's
basically the solutions provided to the
challenge return probability of the 5
most Probab classes and if you know the
true class of the object is within this
five top five most Probab classes we've
got a success so we can see that from
the twenty ten the error rate decrease
by like ten ten times from 28% recent
submission last year was like 2.3
percent in classifying which huge data
set of images with thousands of
categories and we can see like on this
example but the results of the best
solutions whether based on convolutional
neural networks are pretty good yeah
we've got this kind of a container ship
the network thinks okay it's container
ship with high probability it also
thinks maybe tuna lifeboat
possible of drilling platform with very
small probability but it also looks kind
of a drilling platform yeah so all these
predictions of the new Araneta quite
reasonable and basically this huge
progress was possible mainly by two
reasons yeah first was the that we've
got now efficient neural network
architectures for visual information for
images we've got this convolutional
neural networks and was a number of
architectures presented recently like
the quite simple vgg convolutional
neural network set of architectures more
complex architectures like Google
Annette also called inception or ResNet
which is quite deep network with
hundreds of layers and residual
connections and they each you know
provided better and better results and
allowed to classify images with really
high accuracy you can use you know these
architectures in your own projects you
can use like trained them from scratch
or you can use the pre trained
architectures and you know in modern
deep learning libraries like Kara's it
can be done I don't know in twenty-ninth
of code if you've got the data of course
and the second contributing factor to
this great success was large data set of
labeled data so large data sets public
available containing millions of images
label at images like image net which
contains 40 million of labelled images
from 20,000 categories yeah so we've got
images of zebra cat stables dogs and
we've got hundreds of these images or
open image data set 30 million of images
20,000 categories so for average
category we've got like few hundred
images label at images ok few hundred
images of a car from different point of
views but this approach that we take you
know a huge data set with different
different classes of objects and few
hundred a few thousand elements from
each class is not always feasible yeah
but many scenarios when this it does not
apply for example we've got like
pedestrian grade identification right
identification problem when we want too
much image of a person captured by one
CCTV camera and find you know for
matching images from other CCTV cameras
from other security cameras we don't
have hundreds of thousands of images of
a single person we've got only one two
maybe a few so we cannot train a
classifier yeah providing them I don't
know images of ten thousand persons only
two images per person and as going to
classify these persons result would be
terrible and even if we do that then in
practice if you train such classifier
then next day we capture images of next
ten thousand next thousand persons and
what will shall do shall we retrain the
classifier from the scratch to classify
the new persons and you know wait I
don't know one or two days to two photo
training to finish it's not feasible the
same is the file's recognition we
usually don't have hundreds of thousands
images of the face of a single person
we've got only one or two
yeah if we've got our I don't know face
recognition system built-in into our
mobile phone we don't want to take
hundred images of us yeah to be able so
the phone can recognize us so this
scenario when we've got very large
number of classes or even unlimited
number of classes because of face
recognition well we have you know number
of people it's huge we cannot use simple
classification approach the other
scenario when the simple classification
approach is not working is this well
when we look when we search for similar
things like we search for similar images
we provide an image and want to find
similar images here we don't have a
category of classes of categories
assigned to the object we just provide
an image of an object and can be you
know unlimited variety of objects and
we'd like to find something similar a
popular application is for example
searching for similar fashion
items we found some final will say
something that we like made a picture of
some I don't know t-shirt want to
provide it to the system and want the
system to find I know similar offers in
web shops all well can be some
applications from other domains not
visual domain like we want too much
resume to job descriptions for example
also we don't have classes categories
we've got you know the resume the CV and
we want to match find matching job
offers so how to solve these problems
well and here comes the concept of
similarity learning basically instead of
learning how to classify the input it
can be image input image on a sentence
we want to learn how to how we want to
learn how to in think how to input a
similar we want to learn the similarity
between two inputs and this concept of
similarity learning is close related
with distance metric learning but
basically is you know the old task but
we want to learn a metric some kind of
metric measure of distance that assigns
small distances to similar objects like
two images of face of the same person
and large distances to different objects
like images of faces of different
persons well number note which the old
problem and a number of traditional
approaches like principal component
analysis like linear discriminant
analysis neighborhood component analysis
but we can also use especially for
visual data for audio data for natural
language e natural language sentences we
can use given your networks for this to
solve this problem and basically the
idea is to use the neural network to
transform the input data it can be an
image to some low dimensional
representation often called an embedding
here which is actually a vector in
real-valued vector of some fixed length
usually much shorter than the length of
the original image and then distances in
this embedding space actually represent
similarity of the objects just to
visualize how it looks like so basically
we've got our input space it can be
images it can be some encoding of
natural language sentences and we use
neural network to basically transform
this image and this input space has
quite huge dimensionality so if we've
got like this input image 300 by 300 by
3 it's 270,000 dimensions vector quite
huge and we use neural network basically
to enclose this input element into some
lower dimensional vector in this
embedding space representation space but
of course we want to encode it you know
so that this encoding is reasonable it
has the properties that interests us so
basically we want this encoding so the
encoding of similar objects like and all
these cars yeah they are close in the
representation space encoding of
different objects like car and ship they
are quite apart in the representation
space to produce some encoding we can
actually use you know a neural network
and have a choice
basically so a visual information will
likely use convolutional neural networks
if this is natural language sentence
will use probably some kind of a
recurrent neural net its problem domain
a problem dependent but at the as the
result we've got this embedding low
dimensional embedding which we can
efficiently compared with embeddings of
other elements and if we have such
representation how can we use it then to
solve our problem well let's talk about
on the example of this face recognition
so we've got you know images of the
persons in our data set and we've got a
query image for which you would like to
find the identity so what we do is what
we use this convolution on your network
encoder to compute the low dimensional
representations of the images in the
data set
so for each image in the data set we
process once through the network and we
compute very embeddings yeah f ox f of
x1 x2 and then we've got a query image
would like to find identity of this
person we also read it through the
network computed embedding of Q and then
search for the closest embedding in the
embedding space yeah so we've got this
embedding of the query image and third
for the closest embedding in the same
bedding space and basically this these
are relatively low dimensional vectors
and searching for closest vectors in the
Euclidean space it's not hard well
depends of the dimensionality of this
database if it's not huge on the
hundreds of thousands of elements we can
just compare this element with which
each of them and find the closest one we
are using some Euclidean distance or
cosine distance depending on problem if
a lot of these elements like millions
and we are going like we're searching
for similar images and we are going to
do to run I don't know hundreds of
searches per minute we need something
more efficient of efficient libraries
for approximate nearest neighbor search
like flan so we don't have the nearest
neighbor but sometimes we could have the
nearest neighbor some content and
sometimes we can have the second nearest
element but it's quite first so yeah
this works good but the key question is
ok but how do we train the network this
component so it produces the embeddings
but got the desired properties yeah so
the similar objects learnt in the you
know of got similar representations and
this similar objects have kind of a
similar representations with a far apart
very few ways to do it one of the most
popular is so just to reiterate this is
the required property but embeddings of
semantically similar elements like
similar faces needs to be close in the
representation space embeddings of
distant elements needs to be far away in
the representation space one of the most
popular approaches how to do it is to
use samus networks this the name comes
from the you know Siamese twins which
are twins with a connected together so
here we've got samus networks when we've
got two identical neural nets in our
example it's convulsion and your net
because we are processing graphical
information visual information but if
you are processing like natural language
you will likely recommend you aren''t so
these are two identical modules with
shared weights which process power of
examples and we would like to train this
network so when it has you know when the
input is pair of similar things like
images of the same person it computes
this embeddings and computes the
distance between so this part computes
the embeddings of the input elements and
this is basically Euclidean distance
between these embeddings the second norm
of the difference between these two
vectors so weakly done distance so if we
feed similar elements images of the same
person we would like this distance to be
low if we feed these similar elements
like images of different person we would
like to see stuff to be high well how to
train the network to behave like that
basically construct the proper loss
function yeah but will during the
learning will optimize the weights of
the network but it provides as we want
and the most popular loss for training
Sammis networks is this contrastive loss
which consists basically of two terms so
one is the term for positive example so
for positive power when we've had
similar images the images of the same
person we would like these embeddings to
be close so we construct that the loss
is basically the squared distance
between the embeddings you know so the
higher the distance between these
embeddings the higher the loss and it
goes up quadratically
so when train network with this loss is
basically wants to make embeddings of
the same elements as close as possible
of course this is not enough because if
we only use this term then you know the
network we learn to produce embeddings
weather all the same actually of each
input element yeah if for example every
element is mapped zero well perfect yeah
this part of loss is zero because you
know everything is similar to everything
so it's not good so we also need a
second term if the loss function which
is lost for the negative power and this
loss actually pushes the embeddings of
the dissimilar elements apart in
practice we don't want them to be you
know infinitely apart it's sufficient
that they are at least some fixed margin
and apart so basically what this says is
that okay this is the distance between
the embeddings and if this embedding is
actually higher than m and squared then
you know if it's more far away doesn't
matter yeah if it's at least as far as M
loss goes to zero and we have to move it
so how we'll proceed basically we train
the network we provide them
alternatively pairs of similar and
dissimilar elements so we sampras pair
of similar elements from training data
set and compute this positive loss on
this pair then we sample a pair of the
similar elements from our training set
compute this loss and then you know
proceed a standard dual network training
procedure using gradient descent so we
actually fed this similar in the similar
element in bocce's usually we do a
mixture like 50
percent of similar pearl 60% of the
similar pearls each but 11 is part of
each but element is a pair of images we
provide these batches to fed the batches
for our Sammy's net compute the gradient
I use back propagation then to update
the gradient and using the modern neural
network deep neural network
frameworks like Karis up I thought we
can do it with I don't know like 23rd
lines of code so it's pretty easy but
this approach Sammis networks a popular
but they've got one I would say drawback
which is that here we need to specify
which elements are similar which are
dissimilar this may be fine for face
verification because we're either in two
images either of the same person or
different person but if you would like
our network for example trainee to
search for similar fashion items we've
got this degrees of similarity we can
tell that ok one item is most similar to
the other than the third one but we
cannot tell you know hardly but ok this
is similar this is not similar well
these degrees of similarity and we can't
encode this using Sammy's nets so
another popular architecture for similar
little learning to or learning these
embeddings we've got desired properties
the triplet networks and with also very
popular in practice actually I use in
many scenarios even for the face
verification or face recognition when
we've got this card measure of
similarity we also sometimes use to plot
networks and in some papers our false
claim that they perform better when
Sammis networks so it's also worth to
try this one it's also quite easy and
comparable to Sammy's Network the only
difference is that we've got here three
kids on the block so we provide Triplets
of elements to the network we provide
kind of a baseline element is called
anchor in triplet nets papers this
called anchor element we provide one
positive example where is an element
that is kind of a similar to the
a most similar to the UM core and
negative example element but is less
similar or dissimilar if you know if you
are looking for to search for similar
fashion items clothing articles would
provide one item here here we as a
positive example who put something that
is most similar here we put something
that is less similar yet again we've got
here three modules but these are
identical also networks with the shared
weights architecture is domain dependent
for images will have convolution neural
networks we compute the embeddings of
each input element and then we compute
the Euclidean distance between these
embeddings actual height squared
Euclidean distance on this plot and we
want to train the network in that way
but the distance between this positive
example an anchor is low or lower and
distance between anchor and negative
example is higher you are hired by some
margin how to achieve it of course by
designing the proper loss function and
the very popular loss function is the
tripleb loss his reference to the paper
that introduced this loss
it was used in the context of face
recognition in clustering and the strip
rate loss actually so here we've got
only one lost term because we don't have
pairs of negative positive examples with
a triplet that contains both negative
and positive example and it consists of
two terms this term depends on what
anchor and positive example and
basically the higher it is the higher is
the distance between anchor and
embedding of positive example the bigger
is the loss so the loss is driving these
two embeddings together and this part
depends on the distance between the
anchor and negative example so the it's
driving this embedding of negative
example far away and also we want this
difference you know we are happy if this
difference is large of an N so hence the
margin so if the distance
between anchor and negative example is
larger of squared distance is larger
when squared distance between uncle and
positive example larger by this margin M
the loss goes to zero and we are happy
yeah negative example embedding of
negative example is far away when
embedding of positive example from the
anchor and then we can use our favorite
deep learning platform like ours PI
towards you know to run optimization in
this fashion and then we'll we trade the
network we just go a little bit of
surgery just take this one module out of
the Train Network and use it to compute
embeddings of our input data and then as
shown a previous slide we can use this
embeddings to search for similar items
or to compare to find similarity of
elements this looks quite easy but verse
one I would say very important thing
that you if you implement this in
practice you need to remember as always
you know that that some theory can be
nice and easy but then in practice valid
of issues that you need to consider and
it's not always working you know as good
as you want and this is called heart-
mining if you look for papers regarding
triplet network of Sammys nets you will
often find it and also in practice if
you you will implement your solution you
will need to take care of this and
what's the problem here basically okay
he's the triplet laws just written again
so basically is record our data set say
of n people and we've got two images of
each person in the database so the
number of positive examples is you know
linear with the size of the growth
linearly with the size of data set we've
got you know n pairs of images of each
pair song so we've got n positive
examples number of negative examples
goes quadratically
actually the size of data sets so
because we've got you know for each
person we can take n minus 1 negative
examples times - yeah because VN minus 1
other persons
and then all possible pars is and if you
know it's proportional to N squared so
we've got a huge imbalance actually
we've got quite a little number of
positive examples and huge number of
negative examples and if we take a naive
approach where we okay take a positive
example feed it to the network for
training then randomly choose a negative
example then often these negative
examples will be quite easy for the
network because you know we take to eat
two images of the random person they
look quite different they've got you
know different hairstyle completely
different face shape so it's easy to
network to differentiate them and the
network is network is not learning
whereas we are looking you know we want
the network to learn we supped with
differences to differentiate people you
know subtly changes may be in the null
shape lips eyes so we need to somehow to
guide the network and profit to the
network you know these hard examples so
the network can learn on them and what
different strategies to do it basically
one of the popular is that we do it in
like a so-called online batch but online
hard examples mining where we fed the
batch of data from our embedding Network
we compute the embeddings and then
having these embeddings we look for the
hard examples we look for the embedding
of images of face of different persons
but what they're close and these are
hard for the network because network at
the current stage things okay that they
are may be similar but they are not we
know that from the ground truth so we
take these hard examples and you know
useless hard examples to construct
training examples for the network and
then we fed this hard examples hard
negative for the network so it learns to
find these subtle differences some care
is needed with this many because you
know if we provide to the network very
hard example sometimes the outliers in
the data set so which was the hardest
examples as can be in the data set the
network will be often confused and we
well nothing because were the outliers
is will not be able to start learning so
it requires some courage
tension but it's good to refer to the
papers how the Alpha suggests to deal
with it but definitely if you implement
this in practice you will need hard-
mining that's for sure
okay I don't have much time but just
quickly example to see how easy its
implementing Kara's and later for our
links today you know working examples
you can run on your own okay you clear
on these stands for Kara's is if you
don't know deep learning platform I
would say good for beginners because
it's quite easy and you can implement
and run your model in few lines of code
although it's not as flexible as PI
torch but would for starting akedan
distance so it's defined as the
operation of so-called ten source you
have this pencil describe the data that
goes to that neural network is one line
of code back to RA and will it compute
this difference of two vectors which
take a square sum it along the
dimensions of the vector might take a
square root
classical nuclear distance Ram nothing
simple and this contrastive loss for the
siamese network on the example I've
shown you contrastive loss consists of
two terms positive and negative here
they are just glued together this Y is
parameter which says which positive
example y is equal to one so this part
for positive example becomes zero yeah
so here we've got this part and this is
the positive loss its mean of the
basically squared distance between
elements for negative because a negative
example Y becomes 1 so it becomes 0 so
this is 0 because Y here this is 1 and
we take just this margin minus the
distance squared so exactly as you know
as was shown on the formula previously
we define the network this is very
simple for fully connected network of
course for for real-life usage you will
define here some
convulsion on your network or use the
network from the which is predefined in
the library so easily in cars you can
import train alex net for example or
Google +
we define the network and then you know
in these comments basically we create
the Sammis network so we define the
network but it's got two inputs pass
each input through the same network then
where the lambda our layer that computes
the Euclidean distance between the
output of these two layers you know so
it's corresponds to the pic chives on
area and then for the training okay
where is the part but this with three
dots it's creating of a training data
which is you need to implement it by
yourself yeah depending of type of the
data we've got basically to generate the
pairs of data and then when you've got
training pairs defined you compile your
model using this contrastive loss
Sami's Neuros and you run the model
fitting actually training to your model
which will do it with one line of code
and here at the end of just you know a
few URLs for web pages we've got the
simple kind of introductory Sammis
neural network models with the code
first free I encourage the last one is
in fight order I think so you can
experiment for yourself so thank you for
attention
[Applause]
and the questions
thank you for representation one
question when you're defining the data
set the training set
do you pre compute all the pairs
immediately or do you like per Epoque
change the pairs of similar unknowns no
no usually it's not personal defined
area but you know online during the
training because you want to mix them
use where you don't want to you know
pooled at the same pairs in the in
batches so especially from negative
pairs you want kind of to sample them of
course having in mind discard negative
some mining necessary one more question
and it should for these are negative
training so just to make sure I
understood you compute all the
embeddings and then you cluster them and
then from those you generate yeah maybe
not all because you may have a short
data set so what which is well done
you do like you take a bunch of data
from the training data set maybe can't
be random or can't you know you can take
budget sequential you compute embeddings
for or element of the batch and then
having these and batiks computed you
look for the card negatives yeah so the
elements that you know whether
dissimilar from different class but got
close embeddings and this is you know
where your network makes mistake and you
take them I have to construct you know
the to put them in the triplet loss in
this negative Sammis loss so not all
data set but take a batch computing
bedding so run through run it through
the one module of the network include
embeddings construct the find the hard
negatives use it to train the network
and then iteratively you know loop until
your network is trained thanks a million
for your presentation I have a question
actually regarding the calculating
distance between the embeddings seems
like you have to calculate like many
distances for each pair of embeddings so
i was wondering how is it in terms of
like computational expensive cost I'm
just trying to think about how we can
speed up the process of of calculating
each distance in order to find out which
minus T which one
has the closest proximity yeah but you
are talking about network training but
when using the embedding to search for
the closest element yes yes so yeah so
yeah the naive approach when you
compared the embedding of your query
element with which element in data set
takes time so it's fine you've got
thousands of elements but where
libraries but visa you know search for
the approximate nearest neighbors
libraries and they can efficiently
search for nearest neighbors in
Euclidean space and they are know if
you've got the data set of millions or
tens of millions of elements you can use
these one of the libraries for example
flan which is quite old and I know that
there are some new ones for example from
Facebook which speed that up of course
then you don't have you know 100 percent
accuracy
sometimes it will return element that's
not the closest but maybe the second
clause or the first closest is
approximate but it will fly accuracy it
returns the closest element and it's
really really fast
yeah prototypical networks also because
vermin a extension to dislike
prototypical networks actually I tried
on one program prototypical networks but
they were no better than triplet
networks which was quite a surprise for
me because his prototypical networks
actually they optimized the lost
function on the entire batch and want to
actually improve results of the nearest
neighbor search yeah but for my problem
it was not you know much beneficial so I
think it's maybe problem dependent for
some problems
this protocol networks might work better
for some triplet networks I don't think
there's a you know a sharp answer on
this I'm I'm not sure sorry we don't
have time to more questions thank you
thank you
[Applause]